you know like the old gladiator days I
thought that winning came with homeruns
and big contracts and World
Championships and what I realized after
being you know knocked on my ass by my
wrongdoing and my stupidity that turning
the lens inward and pressing the pause
button allowed me to look at things from
a different way and that winning really
was about being a great father a great
partner and in a great leader to to our
team
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
the guest today is Alex Rodriguez or
a-rod if you'd like to call him that
he is quite the businessman now and of
course the baseball legend but something
tells me people are gonna remember him
for his for his business sense and his
successes off the field and so we talked
a lot about that we talked about how a
rod Corp started in 2003 and we talked
about the trajectory of that and what
he's done and where it's going and we
also talked about some of the
transitional times in his life that
weren't so easy I hope you like it so
what I'm most curious off-the-top is is
when you retired what were you most
looking forward to doing that you didn't
have the opportunity to do late you know
and play for such a long time and thank
you for having me in your podcast I
can't wait to hear all of them I played
for 25 years and I think a lot of people
forget sometimes the the first part of
how the arc started and for me was you
know a few months out after my high
school prom I was at Fenway Park as an
18 year old in the major leagues and
while I look I looked like an adult I
was still a child I was 18 and all my
buddies were in great colleges there
were freshman's and here I was facing
Roger Clemens at Fenway scared out of my
mind not having you know getting on the
bus and everybody's calling their wives
and their kids and I'm calling my mother
and it was it was frightening
and you know so when you cut fast
forward to 25 years I was basically in
this kind of silo for 25 years that just
did one thing and did it really well and
it was obsessed the way we get obsessed
as you know so well and I think the
first thing I thought about when I was
done was I knew that I was really done
I never wanted to come back and go and
come back like I was done I was done and
I was really looking forward to resting
my body honestly because I play for so
many years and then I wanted to do I
mean I had like 30 things on my bucket
list
oh that's all yeah there's so much you
sacrifice what you love so much and you
hear everyone the Kentucky Derby and I
did this and I did that and like I did
nothing I had baseballs in nothing is
something that's okay I mean sometimes
the nothing is some things right it's
like what was so so nothing was at the
top of the bucket mm-hmm and the derby
any other fun things like to go or yeah
I like I did one of them this year I did
the Masters in saw Tiger win oh my gosh
that was so fantastic story and great
timing on an era where we need
togetherness we need to think more
collective thoughts as an industry as a
country and it's rare to see one Sunday
where everybody in America is hoping for
one thing and they got it and they
celebrated and that was fun and you only
get that in sports so other things is
just travel with my family be around
more for the Broadway shows of my little
daughters you know Natasha's 14 Ella is
11 and just being a more present dad and
yeah interests enjoying enjoying life
being spontaneous you earned it
you earned it you put in the time now
what were you so glad that you never had
to do again because when I retired I'm
like I'm so glad I don't have to do if
you saw my last year of playing probably
hit again hit again
no I'm just kidding man just just four
more just four more that's right four
more no I I think in general was just
just a grind the grind I mean people
often tell us like oh my god we see on
social media you're so busy it's nothing
compared to what I used to do and what
people don't understand is a sports fan
baseball fans do but I think others is
we played our game is so unique in so
many ways we played 200 games in 232
days relentless
easy from those 32 days off half of them
you flying cross-country and you're
landing somewhere three four in the
morning and you have to go strap it on
the next day so and you get to the
ballpark like what five hours before the
game a lot of times and then you have
the game which ya know if you're a very
long time sometimes sometimes if I knew
what I know now there's no way I can go
back and do it 25 years so 20 you say
that because that's what I was thinking
at the end - as I said when I'm gone I
think I'm gonna look back at this
schedule and the things that I did and
go how did I do it you're like geez how
did I have the energy how did I stay
focused how was I able to
compartmentalize right because you still
have all those aspects of your life
family you still work you still have you
still have a rod Corp you say have all
kinds of things going on but yet you
managed it all and it just feels so much
lighter I don't know if you feel like
that but I feel so much lighter now yeah
plane doing what we do in many ways and
especially here in New York City where
everybody is a fan is a critic lives for
it every pitch and you're only as good
as the last night's ballgame you know as
you walk around the streets of New York
yeah is the best city - it's it's like
running a public company because the
shareholders are the fans and the fans
are the great great policemen they're
firefighters they're the teachers they
let the one thing about Yankee baseball
you watch the YES Network is every night
is in your living room but I have a
question for you so you you raised for
all these years you must have thought
you were probably really happy that uber
came up with you never have to drive
again go to get in a car and go
somewhere and somebody's like do you
want to drive or like Aaron will be like
you know be about driving like we went
to a Bucs game one night and he was like
I don't really want to drive him like
I'm happy to drive so I totally don't
mind it it is very handy though over is
very handy you like a rod get out of the
way yeah it's not a fraud I love road
trips my parameters are five hours so
anything within five hours to me it's
you know I'll Drive it three is like why
wouldn't you drive it to me he doesn't
have maybe exact
parameters is that but but I don't mind
driving at all but my question is like
it would be you driving like on central
park here it's almost like me going to
play Little League baseball
no driving look at me no driving in New
York I leave that up to I believe that
identify actually have never driven in
New York City have you driven in New
York City yeah okay all right well you
amateur you're one up on me there okay
tell me about a rod Corp I'm super this
is I love an athlete that can branch out
that is you know curious about other
things and multi-dimensional I mean I
know you started a rot a rod Corp in
2003 and it's been going on for a long
time so you know I'd love to hear the
story about you know what really drove
you to get that started and then you
know eventually like what are you
pushing with that guy it was fear it was
fear I was scared out of my mind you
know the buzzword in sports right now is
you know analytics sabermetrics big data
right and everything is but what they
don't realize that sometimes that is
still a human game as a human person
that gets behind the wheel is a human
person that you know gets put on
pinstripes and I started looking at some
data early on for whatever reason when I
was 10 years old I had a dream to be a
baseball player and I wanted to be a CEO
of a major company don't tell me why I
was thinking that at 10 I was and oh my
god and what happened I mean not an
inspiration to dream I believe in the
power of manifesting creating a goal
having a vision and I think that power
of visualization is real so okay you're
10 years old and you make these things
happen and it's also one of the reasons
why I think athletes have a great
potential and they follow the rule book
the playbook
that can be great great business men and
women what do you mean by that follow
the playbook yes in their sport er I'll
tell you about that ok good I think is
super important right and again endless
potential but my mother we never had
money to buy a house we never owned
anything and I saw my mother rent all
the time so we were tenants and you know
she served tables the mornings I'm sorry
she was secretary in the morning sort of
table at night and I just felt
the stress that she counted her money
every night and I would help her
2220 is that how you good good at
numbers you like numbers right I've
always been pretty good at numbers
understanding numbers and I got down on
my knees when I was about 12 years old
and I said dear dear Lord if I can have
two wishes one can you slow down time
for my mother because every 30 days
feels like every three days and I feel
the pressure of her having to pay her
bills and then the other one is if I can
ever trade places with the landlord and
be the landlord another tenant if I ever
get that opportunity I'm going to take
that chance
and that ROM won't have to pay and then
maybe mom won't have to work and I was
22 I had my first opportunity to make my
first investment I did I had it needed a
$48,000 downpayment I bought a duplex
then I sold that several years later for
almost double and then about eight units
and then 60 and then I grew that
portfolio from two units to about you
know twelve or thirteen thousand
apartment units in about fourteen states
all over the southeast
they're also a little part of the story
to where you had to sell some Rolex oh
yeah yeah
in order for me to it's funny you're
selling Rolexes to do this another thing
which is fantastic right it's a good one
of them is something you can't wear I
mean you can't live in your Rolex right
you just have it on and it's just part
of a facade on some level I mean it just
anything tells time a Rolex is just the
fancy version of it it's a nice car
but you at a young age said this doesn't
gonna help me that's right and you know
when you're from Miami like I am the
first thing you do when you sign a
professional contract is you buy a nice
car and you buy a Rolex so that's what I
did
that's right well what car did you buy
then I ended up buying a Jeep Cherokee
black with cool rims and yeah I was I
was 18 I thought it was pretty cool yeah
it is so so what I realized was that the
difference early on of an asset versus a
liability and a lot of folks at home
don't realize that a house is not an
asset is a liability in apartment units
it's an asset not a liability why
because a home you have to take money
out of your pocket every month and pay
that house mortgage rent insurance taxes
all of that an apartment building puts
money in your pocket everyone and you
want more assets
and less liability so that was you so
that's why I started investing into
apartment I'm thinking about my house is
an assets so I like how did you even who
gave you the idea at 22 to start
thinking about me
the only thing I was thinking about it
twenty-two is getting facials cuz I'm
like look I'm gonna get old someday I've
ever get this thing cleaned up so like
that's what I was thinking about at 22 I
wasn't thinking about taking my money
and investing into apartments or
starting a company I mean that's I mean
and I feel like I was you know I matured
pretty fast but that's you know fears it
just came out I mean you were just out
of high school like yeah I was scared I
saw my mother the way she had to work I
saw fear and I son numbers give you some
numbers they're pretty incredible so if
you think about a baseball player that's
what I play so five and a half years is
the average career five point five and
you make 90% of your money from age 20
to 30 right said begs the question what
happens I'm 31 to 80 and then we have
750 players 750 from those 750 less than
5% have a college degree so just with
that information alone I'm not a stock
broker I was short to stock and that's
why you see players in sports going
bankrupt or some financial stress at an
80 percent clip so because of that I
thought that if I bought five and a half
assets if I played the average and I was
22 and I would have a 15 or 20 year
mortgage on my assets then I will pay
this mortgage down and at 35 to 40 I
would have five and a half assets with
no debt and that was my insurance and my
answer to bankruptcy and that's how it
started Wow
that's some that's some looking forward
so your mom must have been good with
money then was your mom good with me to
raise I mean to be a single mom with you
know a few kids I mean that's you know
what it's good to be aware at least
Danica is so funny when I think about my
mother and you know we we have we always
are fighting what it's called the
zipcode war which means you know as an
adult
a very very high percentage of where you
end up is based on what your zip code is
and in order to fight a zip code war we
have to give kids knowledge because
knowledge is power
and they have to understand that they
could be an a-rod they could be a Aaron
Rodgers they're gonna be Danica they can
be Sheryl Sandberg there's a lot of
people they can be but we have to show
them the way and give them the tools so
they can be addicted early in good
things right and I think financial
literacy is where we have one of the
biggest opportunities the fact that they
don't teach financial literacy in middle
school and high school is a tragedy and
and that needs to change I think there's
a lot of criteria to be honest in school
that's pretty pointless yeah I don't
know how you feel about it all but I
mean you have kids what do you think
about school like when you think about
the system well I look I think there's
I'm a fundamentalist by Nature I'm also
in some ways a traditionalist so I do
believe that there's a lot of good that
comes out of the the formal academic
system especially if you have good
schools and good teachers right for time
management it's good for you know being
responsible right but like curriculum
wise I think look I go to I go to the
biggest things that you need I think are
EQ but the underlining values that you
also need are especially in business you
know you need math skills accounting
there's some things that you need the
more you have the better but there's
about 50 or 40% of it you can just say I
don't need any of this I don't know
about you but I didn't really use I
didn't really use a lot of human anatomy
right or biology or algebra 2 and now
mind you I have a GED so I was done with
school halfway through my junior year
and then I moved to England and started
racing so Murray cars I had been
go-karts up until that point so I don't
have I don't even have I have a chi IDI
that works so you know so do i I don't
have a college degree you don't have a
college degree I don't think we're great
advocates for college you enough yeah I
think we are I mean the way that I've
seen you start your winery and you're
into fitness and you have your line
coming out you just roll your second
book right which I cannot wait to read
it give me the name again
pretty intense yeah it's then it's there
you go pretty good transition into this
I love it pivoting second and third acts
I'm a student at heart and I'm a teacher
at heart right by nature I love to learn
I love and I love to share my lesson
then I usually lead with my mistakes and
then the lessons learned from my
mistakes just when I look at my mentors
I have two set of mentors people that
have done it amazingly that I want to
strive to be like them
and then others that I make radical
mistakes and then you learn even more
from those let's talk about one that
costs four and a half million dollars to
go to lunch with okay you probably know
who that would be mr. Buffett yes okay I
just read that just this morning that
someone paid 4.5 million dollars for
lunch and this is someone that I
wouldn't do you call my friend yeah a
friend and a mentor and how how did that
happen I'm actually having dinner with
him here in the next few weeks in Omaha
you know what happened was in 2001 when
I left the Seattle Mariners I was a free
agent and I signed with the Texas
Rangers and I signed for two hundred and
fifty two million dollars and I couldn't
believe when they told me that I'm like
what someone's gonna pay me of that
mm-hmm
are they drunk did that good there's a
weight that's carried with that oh yeah
it was enormous like you know Tom Hicks
who was now a good friend and someone
who I look at as a mentor and in his
entire family this incredible weight
that goes with that and there's a stress
level and I'm used to just playing
baseball not being an enterprise so and
it was probably too much too early I was
only 24 25 I mean like what but Warren
ironically enough because the contract
was so large no one's asked me about
this before it's a great question we
needed the last three years of a 10-year
contract to be insured and the last
three years are always the most
expensive and and the most so is that a
baseball thing or is this a youth thing
why does there need to be insurance I
paid Annika a hundred million dollars
that's fine I would pay an insurance
policy say Jeff over there
Ron I would say Ron I want you to ensure
my contract with Danica if anything
happens to her my three million dollars
then it pumps so you'll pay her salary
so I'm ensure that if you're healthy I'm
good but if you go down then Ron
insurance pays for your contract then
I'm off the hook right so because this
contract was so large Warren Buffett
ended up insuring it and in the contract
was approved because they had full
insurance and then thank God for Warren
right when I heard this story I was like
what that's cool that's so sick that's
so cool so I of course cold email like I
do all the time to people and that takes
guts and I say about that like that's
never thinking and that I would get I'm
Alex Rodriguez from Miami why is Warren
Buffett whatever and to my email I'm I
was a kid right and Debbie who's still
there she's been there many many years
just warned you know chief of staff
running the running camp down in Omaha
she wrote back and she goes yeah Warren
would love to see you and house the next
few weeks I'm like I'm there I'm there
yes yes yesterday and then I ended up
going you know a handful of years back
to back to back to to spend four or five
hours with him and our running joke was
that you're insuring my ass off
yeah did you play through a fitness test
yeah you see whatever you want you can
swear I'll get my ass off so you your
money's good with me and that was
erratum I need you to do a hundred
push-ups and hundred pull-ups just to
make sure this insurance is good right
well we would order he would say well
make sure you give him some vegetables
cuz yesterday what was it like a review
I mean like you said did you meet with
him every year you said it probably so
was it some kind of like did you have
like the ultimate year-end review with
Warren Buffett or was this just like hey
we're buddies let's get to know each
other better or was there a agenda or I
mean I would just say it's a little bit
of combination of all of that but of
course you can't sit down with Warren
for four hours and I'd say hey what do
you I'm gonna give you a year in review
of what we're doing kind of what your
overall thoughts he would kind of dig in
a little bit with me and give me some
great suggestions and requests some
things and
it was like amazing it's their one that
was like I mean it's there's things that
stand out and other things that he gave
you a suggestions that you thought to
yourself I'm speaking from experience
like were you thinking
that's probably not a good idea that's
not gonna work or why would I do that
and then you do it and you're like oh my
god it really should start listening to
people it was funny yeah there's a few
but the one thing that I said as I left
his office in Omaha I said you know
Warren can you give me some advice kind
of going into the season whether there's
baseball or business or family and he
goes yeah I said hold on let me take out
a pen in a place where I gotta write
everything everything so I take out a
pen and a paper
respectful yeah he goes oh you won't
need that it's super simple I go okay
he's like put it down I go okay I put it
down he goes number one be the best
baseball player you can be and finally
number two he goes be a gentleman I go
that's it he goes yeah hold on let me
write that down
wait talk about simplicity right be a
good baseball player and be a gentleman
and he's right what year was that then
um I would guess that was like my Texas
years oh yeah that would been yeah
possibly
I would say between like Oh 306 window
yeah fantastic
what else is uh what else is a-rod Corp
doing I mean I know you have true fusion
my girlfriend I she goes to the one in
Scottsdale and she said you were there I
was like oh yeah he came in we got to
get you guys out there like yeah she
said it's fantastic I'm a dick he was
noting the heat and I know you do a
little yoga and CrossFit
yeah I did so it's a little bit of I
would say a hybrid between yoga CrossFit
and in course you get a little lifting a
little stretch in core so some ass
perfect yeah and you sweat which I'm not
a sweater so it helps me sweat so I
would say is the recital we talk about
real estate you know we do a lot in the
consumers or anything other than
apartments within the real estate yeah
that's not portfolio yeah you're good
good question so fully integrated in the
real estate company alone we have
anywhere from 75 to a hundred people
that run that full-time oh my
a lot of them out on the field managing
our properties Wow like I was a 2225 in
corporate running the whole real estate
and there's three things we do in real
estate number one thing we do is we
invest in multifamily apartments and
secondary and tertiary markets like
North Carolina South Carolina but no way
a little bit right Midwest southeast the
perfect formula in life in when it comes
to business sports and business merger
is if you take a young kid that went to
University of Michigan and he goes down
and throws a bunch of he says I'm gonna
go out and throw touchdowns and graduate
from Michigan then I'm gonna go to the
NFL when a bunch of Super Bowls and that
person meets a young kid with a crew-cut
from Omaha Nebraska and says I'm gonna
make all this money you're broke but I'm
gonna make all this money I'm gonna give
it to you and you invest it and that
combination is Tom Brady
with Warren Buffett and if they met a 21
and they merge they would have built
essentially what Buffett and Munger
built but is you have to identify who is
your Warren Buffett in your town and if
you're aligned from a moral compass you
trust this person and then you have a
great lawyer to help you I always say
like if you're gonna do ten million
dollars I want to do a hundred I want to
go right behind you and I'm gonna learn
I'm gonna be on every call and one of
the things that really gets me upset
is that you have to do mystify business
they have all these fancy terms and
total BS oh it took another language
they try and hide behind a different
language if I'm gonna do ten million
dollars into a company and you know
we're gonna take our entire a record
team and put all our intelligence and
experience and due diligence and then
we're gonna take our brand and we're
gonna drive incredible value and then I
tell you my partners Marc Lasry who you
know well and I say he's gonna do ten
I'm gonna do ten do you and Erin want to
do a hundred hundred and you go wait I
gotta call my agent I call your agent
wait I gotta call my business manager
and then I gotta call my lawyer
but the tenant guys do that for the next
four weeks we're on to the second and
third deal yeah and the thing you have
to remember is like why
look behind you when you look at in
front of you you're saying I trust Alex
I trust Lazar II I trust and and then
you have a lawyer to structure a good
deal with us but all you're doing is
you're going for a great ride and you're
learning yeah so have you been it hard I
would have you bet it hard like have you
gone man there's ten million dollars out
the window that obviously didn't go so
well because that's the thing about
looking forward not looking back that's
the thing about jumping in and I get it
I love it I'm much more like that I am
I'm all about having less diminishing
returns on my investment of time like if
it's gonna take me if I'm gonna learn
this much more for that much more effort
but I can just kind of figure it out a
little bit here go for it like i'ma go
for it kind of person but it can get you
in trouble sometimes okay so it's a
great question and in annoy we have some
terrible times with our banks because we
bought a portfolio I'll give you one
example we bought five we have a bad
time overall but but to your point is
where you learn your bigges lessons
right yeah we have we bought a portfolio
of 500 units we paid a 60 thousand per
door in one day was worth you know 60
the next day was worth 40 wheeled 42 so
we were underwater so then we had to go
out him to the bank and negotiate for
like a year to basically write them a
check have a big write down and
eventually those properties came
together the bank was our partner and we
all won but that was some luck that was
a lot of skill that we had to go in and
manage and be patient the point is this
the point is if you get to do business
with me and you think there's value
there or Marc Lasry
or whoever that person in your community
is then you say this I can afford a
hundred thousand but I'm gonna do twenty
because if I do twenty and it in a goes
out the window it was worth the lesson
to do business totally see you so would
you recommend that people only spend
what they're willing to lose I think
that's a good way to start I would say
don't invest unless you understand the
business right have passion for the
business do not invest just because you
think is gonna be a good investment I
would say understand it have a passion
be disciplined but eventually you have
to trust yourself but do due diligence
right yeah
get in a car race with you and say
Danica lit lit I'm gonna I'm gonna play
for a million dollars I'm gonna race you
for a million dollars but yet athletes
want to come into our arena yeah right
look at that that's great that's you
yeah I mean look it's been 15 years 16
years that you've had the company and
and you aren't a player anymore so you
know you should be proud of that so keep
going though I'm really like that's a
very cool transition that you've reached
so no I think look you have an
incredible competitive advantage that
you can meet with anyone you want and
then yeah you have to like it right like
if you like winery like that's a that's
a bold move I would never get into wine
and because right yeah I just like
drinking it so I'm like how do I do this
if you told me Alex you know we're doing
this investment for XY reasons and you
see me a path and I and you say to me
you'd say XYZ I mean look at it and yeah
I may say Jeff run it through lane and
let's see if there's anything there we
would like to support Danica because we
think long-term we can do other big
things with Danica and some of our
consumer business or something else but
yeah we may take a flier and we may do
maybe a third of what makes us feel very
comfortable or maybe a quarter but it's
important to you that we support you and
one of the things we do a terawatt Corp
is we empower women and women founders
of course me coming from my mother and
to a mother and two daughters or sister
is the ability that we want women to be
better stronger faster equality is super
important to us and truly have a seat at
the table not just do it because the
right thing to do yeah so finish your
other buckets because I want I think
that's important that people understand
how to versified you are so real estate
consumer media and entertainment and
then health and wellness so think about
four things real estate health and
wellness consumer media entertainment so
we we are very very deep into health and
wellness
you know from companies that we work
with like crunch and UFC James and true
fusion and we bought a big business in
India for low-cost yoga Wow how did it
we love India we love the numbers there
is one of the fastest-growing economies
in I went there last year we went there
and we met the methodology Lama and it
was a fascinating country right and look
if they're on the path to sort of
turning things over and making it nice
cuz yeah there's a lot of areas that
India could use some help but man it's
gonna if it is stay in it yeah and we
did that because we want data from India
we want to see what's going on we want
to be on the ground data is money we
want to learn I mean that's what we've
learned yeah so you don't need the money
like that's just like plain and simple
at the end of the day I mean what
motivates you to work this hard to to do
your due diligence and what could
presumably sometimes not be that
exciting you know like a an apartment in
somewhere is like okay the due diligence
maybe not super exciting so what part in
there is for you right it's sometimes
it's not the thing it's like the thing
about it it's like for me about racing
like I didn't love racing
I loved the journey I loved getting
setting a goal and achieving it I loved
making the car better I loved having
hope to do better so like there was
there was threads in there that I loved
but it wasn't the actual thing so what
is it about business for you that is
like appealing and draws you in I
thought I think that collaborating
making others dreams come true there's
nothing better than having someone at a
walk or making their first million and
making a millionaire for the first time
yeah that's an amazing thing look I was
I'm a byproduct of great great mentors
my mother was so busy working that I
needed to lean on the Boys and Girls
Club great coaches great teachers
I still remember miss Morales in the
fourth grade chasing me in the bathroom
because I was eating an apple and she
was young man you never take food into
the bathroom you know to this day that
lesson was a you know is important to me
or something that I talked to my
daughters about you know I I'm
incredibly inquisitive about you know
your journey
it's an incredibly inquisitive person
and I think that you know pre-suspension
you know like the old gladiator days I
thought that winning came with home runs
and big contracts and World
Championships and what I realized after
being you know knocked on my ass by my
wrongdoing and my stupidity that turning
the lens inward and pressing the pause
button allowed me to look at things from
a different way and that winning really
was about being a great father a great
partner and and a great leader to to our
team
I would like to dive into that if
possible to understand emotionally how
you felt and then after the suspension
and you've talked about it being a
paradigm shift for you and what happened
right we have to the only way to the
other side is through mm-hmm so what did
you go through well I think for one what
I've learned is that and I'll tell you
what I went through is that you're an
average of the five people you surround
yourself with the most right amen and
when I realized every time I screwed up
in a big way I did it by myself
anytime I did anything that meant
anything I did it with great people
around me and you know you find yourself
in a situation and you make mistakes and
then you how you handle that mistakes
makes it that much worse I made a
mistake and then I doubled down and
wasn't clear about my message and and
really did I have the tools to even
communicate what I was going through at
the time and at some point I'll get a
chance to to talk about everything maybe
in detail maybe not but the big picture
that I'm ready to tell you here is that
I made mistakes
I double down and as a result of that I
served the longest suspension in Major
League Baseball history for peds and
while I was hoping it was a 50-game
suspension like the other you know 15 or
so guys it was 211 for the same penalty
and it that just
literally took me to my knees and tears
and said oh my god I just completely
[ __ ] up my entire life and we're gonna
play again 100% of them I mean new
baseball was done it was the darkest
time of my entire life what did that
look like I mean I remember when I got
the call and two eleven got reduced to
162 which is our entire season in
baseball and when Tony Clarke from the
Union called I went down to one knee
two knees in my home in Miami Beach I
was there by myself I was waiting for
that call that you never want to get and
it rang three times and I picked up the
phone and I said hello and we were on
the phone for two minutes and it felt
like two hours and Tony says alex is 162
and immediately the minute he said that
like I had tears coming down my eyes and
I went down to my knee to my knees and
just like oh my god it's it's over what
what have I done to myself and at that
point I was still kind of in denial as
his fall does this father's not you know
do you think that was part of the
problem you were in denial about it that
was the entire problem about who was
responsible for it really all of it all
of it the answer is yes it was my fault
in every way and that's what I've
learned I like going back to that house
I want to tell you this because this
part is important I for three weeks I
basically didn't leave my house you know
a couple weeks I was just so sad I
didn't see my daughter's Wow
I was sick to my stomach I would wake up
in the middle of the night like in tears
and going like I'm the only jackass that
has pocket aces that finds a way to lose
his [ __ ] hand is so painful and you
know try to grow a beard it couldn't
yeah and then that's it the entire year
allowed me to put a plan together to
come back so you had plenty of time to
reflect maybe even figured it out in the
three weeks after I'm not sure I don't
know but did you look back and figure
out like could you identify what it was
that
drove you to feel like you could do what
you did mm-hmm
and get away with it mm-hmm or that you
should do it or you needed to do it or
were you able to like nail down what
personality trait or what pattern you
were repeating that you had to escape
mm-hmm well I think what what the 162
allowed me to do it allowed me to press
the pause button and turn the lens
inward and start to dig in and some of
the questions asked right yeah and I
wanted to know what the hell happened
between the age 5 and 12 that made me do
all these stupid things yeah in self
destruct I mean think about it I had
hundreds of millions of dollars
guaranteed whether I played another game
or not it's like crazy right it's crazy
and it's so upsetting and what I
realized all in all is that I was flawed
and and these mistakes were from your
from your youth yeah and look the one
thing is that realize I'm still I still
do my work in therapy and and that's a
journey that's never gonna stop sure I
mean it allowed me to look at the world
in a different place that I am grateful
to be one of 750 major league players
that I'm grateful to be a New York
Yankee that I'm grateful to have George
Steinbrenner bring me to New York and
then I [ __ ] it up and I disappointed
and there's no excuses and once I own
that and once I looked in the mirror and
said it was you and not the handler at
the PR not not wrong not my attorney it
was me but you stopped making excuses
for yourself I actually for the first
time and that I ended up seeing a little
bit of light at the end of the tunnel
yeah it was it was a little light it's a
crack and then it opens up so where did
the opening up take you then well it
took me up to my therapy it took me had
you ever been a therapy before that I
have but not like this and I was for
that yeah yeah this was like a deep deep
dive and look if I had a 50-game
suspension I couldn't dive that deep
into the bottom of the ocean to see what
was the bottom yeah I had to just do
something - where was more banded like
and I had to go back and play baseball
it's
time's our therapies driven towards a
relationship or a situation as opposed
to like this is for me and I said I
would always say to any of my friends
and I've been to therapy before my
friends have been to therapies like my
advice though is it's for you
it's just for you and if you want to
come together at some point fine but
it's really for you to do the work
mm-hmm so did you go to therapy and just
lose it that's what I've done Kenny
there's something about saying the words
I don't know how you feel but like
saying the words out loud about
admitting something that you feel or
something that you've done or something
that you're scared of maybe something
from your past that you just haven't
brought up did you feed you is that some
where you get to in your therapy the
whole thing was so difficult and I had
to go through so much crap sometimes you
just sit in the couch for two hours and
don't say a word as a staring match and
you know I'm a Leo and you try to be
stubborn one you know you are no you won
that your I mean I'm super stubborn too
I never win against my therapist never
heard he's undefeated that's how I stole
the job yeah I don't know how but he
does he's really good
okay I'm grateful to him in many ways he
saved my life
yeah look therapy's super personal yeah
so what are the new what are the what
are the things that you've come away
from like whether it's I mean even new
patterns now but but but after for sure
that you said look from now on this is
this is my new reaction because I've got
those stories to where I used to react a
certain way and the first step was
acknowledging it and going oh I see this
now because you can't fix what you don't
know is there and then once you start
acknowledging it you have the flip and
you switch it to the way that you want
to react to something or the way you
want to think and then all of a sudden
that starts becoming more normal and now
listen you kind of become a new new
better version of yourself yeah so what
what was in that sort of conversion that
you were like I'm gonna flip this this
is these are not these are not patterns
I want to have anymore yeah what I
realized is when when I I became a
millionaire at the age of 18 and what
you realize is you become a
old brat and that's what I became and
not saying that I was all bad I was I
was a nice guy but there was entitlement
and there were issues and as you become
a bigger bigger star and you make more
money what I realized was your blind
spot gets bigger and bigger and if you
don't have the right people around you
to help you manage that with a therapist
or friends or family then it just keeps
getting bigger and then of control and
what I realize coming out of the
suspension was that self-awareness is
one of the most important attributes
that we can have first understanding
that you have major blind spots and you
know as I wake up every day is a few
thoughts of being grateful and
diminishing the ego and surrounding
yourself with people that are different
than you in many ways and complement
your set of skills but have a moral
compass that are gonna keep you in check
as well and and that's one way to check
that make sure that that blind spot is
always being covered there's a great
quote that's your new life's gonna cost
your old one mm-hmm
were there things people things that
went by the wayside when things changed
they're people that you no longer
because they think that's scary right
people that's a scary thing to think you
know my new life's gonna cost me my old
one and so many things are gonna change
and change is scary to people but you
know I don't think we're actually scared
of the change because it's usually for
the better right that's the intention
it's the fact that something goes away
so was there were the things that had to
go away or was it truly just a self go
work on yourself and then everything
else appeared different maybe it was
about perception well I think it's a
little bit of of everything right I mean
change is difficult and you know we're
beans that like being comfortable in
this comfort zone right getting out of
that comfort zone is hard and it takes a
lot of work and it takes out a trust and
conviction and it's one of the hardest
things I've had to do but when you get
to the other side of that yeah I
understand that you've never really
arrived you always have to continue to
work and
we're flawed and as an evolution and
keeping that humility and being grateful
for for that is important but yeah I
mean look in order to do better things
you do have to change talk about your
kids a little bit you know I know you
come from a strong mother you know what
what kind of values having gone through
so many things in your life good and bad
like what are the important you talk
about a moral compass what are the
important values that you try and
instill in them so that they can have
the best possible happy future you know
a lot of it is just loving and
supporting them and help guiding them
when they need guidance but a lot of it
is let them fly as as far and as high as
they can but being present and loving
and not in a judgmental way we're here
to help and help you lead the way a
little bit but ironically enough again
the mistakes to me or where I get an
opportunity to to say this is what daddy
did and this is the good there's a bad
there's the ugly and you want to stay
away from the latter
too and again those honest conversations
even as a father going back to them and
saying daddy made a mistake I think is
an investment into our relationship in
the future because I never want them to
[ __ ] daddy
when when the tough gets going and you
know having teenage daughters I have one
already and a couple more on the way
that's a scary thought so that is one of
the hardest things I had to do but
hoping that one day they would come
clean with me when they have to I have
to imagine in this world today it is
hard to raise kids there's so much going
on with social media with confidence and
you know is that a struggle like I am
always curious about Alaska I mean where
I mean it's a full-time job you know and
are they allowed to do selfies of
themselves
oh my god yeah they wouldn't exist with
you there
but you know it's it the two things is
like they know so much more than us you
know my oldest daughter told me other
days like that if we want to do
something you'll never catch us because
you're you don't know anything about the
way we do things social media and
they're right and then I went to Cynthia
their mamas and you know Natasha told me
cuz I think she's right is there so
should we hire she'll want to help us
with the social media police and they're
skilled like they're there innately like
better than us at it um and that's a
different world they know you just said
and pray just that you know it's his you
know I remember the days we grew up in
our friends were in our homeroom in our
first period and second period class
yeah now the entire world is you always
sit through social media yeah it is a
scary place it's um
how much do you share how much do you
not and is there any rules on that well
first of all I mean especially living in
a loaded household with public people my
one daughter Ella does not we took her
off social media so she's in fifth grade
she's a rising sixth grader and Natasha
doesn't allow me to follow her she was
had my social medias enough for you but
trust me I get another social stalker
then oh yeah I can sneak in til their
accounts and watch what she's doing
because she's just knowing she will now
[Laughter]
okay
so I just love to hear about your you
know you have truth fusion
you've been athlete all your life now
you're a business mogul but that doesn't
mean that you forget about the athletic
side of things and training and
nutrition so I'm just kind of curious I
always love to hear you know what is
your what is your routine what's your
regiment yeah I cannot wait till we have
true fusion in every state that when we
land some we can go take a classes as a
team we love working out together but
look I think health wellness nutrition
you know getting proper sleep you know
staying hydrated all those things are
always going to be a big part of my life
and and we think it's incredibly
important to even our culture and our
company so that what you do is true
fusion or do you do do you do like you
have a trainer do you lift weights I try
to do a little bit
I do a lot of yoga yeah yoga
I lift I don't run as much anymore
because two bad hips and two two knee
surgeries so I try to stay away from not
along can't imagine my oldest CrossFit
little CrossFit a little bit across this
what do I do CrossFit mostly and I do
yoga how many days a week um I have to
force myself to take a day off I'm one
of those people I like to days even Wow
so I love that I usually have a CrossFit
session and then instead of sometimes
I'll do like a 20 30 minute cardio
interval session sometimes I'll take a
hour to walk with the dog sometimes I'll
do yoga but I usually do two things a
day if I'm not super busy if I am then
some days I do not like today I got up
early came so I didn't do any what I do
today nothing today
so no lifting no I won't I'm when I if I
have to wake up before 6:00 a.m. to work
out I decide that I'm busy enough that
day that I don't need to do anything got
it
and plus I always say I don't plan off
days I don't plan rest days cuz they
naturally happen right I just think that
you know life gets to you and whether
you know you're you know you get busy
with something with kids or plans change
or you got a hangover like look at plans
you know life life builds in your rest
days for you
so okay do you do so you do look a
little Olympic lifting then yeah yeah
yeah I like it okay yeah I get bored
easily you know I agree what what is
your what is your strength in yoga
balance when is over and then so diet
wise I mean I'm if there's two things I
do a lot of its work out and cook so I
love food and my diet is always an
evolution but do you follow anything in
particular or do you just I just think
we again I think those changes build in
but I like moderation I like you know my
proteins I'm like some low carbs and
trying to eat the right carbs and a
little bit of fat but I think balance is
good I'm not a drinker so that that
helps that is very helpful dad that's
really helpful
do you cook then no I can't cook oh my
god no no but Jennifer's a great
well that's good that's good well
alright well I see people standing up so
thank you so much for being on the show
I really appreciate it I love sharing
and being honest and vulnerable thank
you very much thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it and also
thank you so much Trevor Hall for the
awesome music if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button
[Music]